ashley's with us in sacramento hi ashley
what's up
hi how are you doing great how can we
help
um so i just have a question so
my husband and i were we're debt-free we
luckily
were able to get through school without
any debt
and my husband just landed his first job
out of school
and he's making some good money so we
opened up
with his 401k and then also opened up a
roth
ira and we've been contributing a little
bit
um but i know you recommend 15
to go towards retirement but we're also
trying to
save for a down payment so i was
wondering do you still
recommend the 15 while we're trying to
save for that or
is it okay to do a little less or okay
how old are you guys
um i'm 21 and he's 24. okay
well first let's establish you've got
some time
there's not a rule that says you go to
hell if you don't buy a house by 25.
okay you're gonna be okay you're gonna
you've got a little time to work on this
you don't have to panic
you're going to be just fine and you've
done a really good job so far
very well done all right two things one
is we teach a process called the baby
steps
one is a thousand dollars saved you've
done that two is debt free you've done
that
three is a fully funded emergency fund
of three to six months of expenses have
you got that
yes we do good excellent okay and what's
your household income
um so he's making sixty thousand months
little
job searching that's cool so what do you
think you'll be making when you land
something
um probably around thirty okay so you
have a roughly a hundred thousand dollar
income 90 to 100k
right in there and you're just beginning
your career so it'll go up that's
excellent okay now we teach after people
are at baby step three they have their
emergency phone and they're debt-free if
they
are ready to buy a home at that point
then you would save up your down payment
if you want to put your retirement
savings on hold temporarily we call that
baby step
3b baby step 3 being the emergency fund
3b
be being saved for the down payment on
your home okay okay and if you want to
so if you want to sit out of retirement
for two years
or three years and pile up cash very
rapidly now the other thing i'm hearing
is i think i'm hearing you're not on a
written budget
and you guys need to get a detailed
written game plan because
you would have known exactly what was
going on you've got general concepts and
again you've done a really good job but
i want you to get in a detailed written
budget
jump on every dollar it's an app you can
download for free
and start to figure out how to put that
budget together or look at a free
uh trial at ramsey plus where you can
use the every dollar
premium budget version and get through
the classes as well